And the midianites sold Joseph into
Egypt,
unto Potiphar,
an officer of Pharaohs and captain of
the guard.
And Joseph was brought down to Egypt and
Potiphar,
an officer of Pharaoh,
captain of the guard,
and the Egyptian bought him of the hands
of the Ishmaelites,
which had brought him down thither.
So now he's a slave.
So now you'd think,
well that would be,
this is a man who has a lot of reason to
be irritated at the structure of
reality.
Right?
He's gone from being the favorite to
being betrayed by all of his brothers.
That's pretty rough.
And then he's being transformed into a
slave and now he's being.
He's being sold to work as a slave.
So you'd think that that would corrupt
his character because you know,
one of the things,
I think this is the case anyways,
I think people are always looking for an
excuse to have their character
corrupted.
Because if your character is corrupted,
then you get to lie and you get to cheat
and you get to steal and you get to be
trade.
You get to act resentfully and you get
to do nothing.
And that's all easy.
It's easier to lie than to tell the
truth.
It's easier to do nothing than to do
something.
So there's always part of you thinking,
well,
I need a justification for being useless
and horrible because that,
that'd be a lot less work.
And so then if something terrible comes
along,
you think a,
that's just exactly the excuse that I
was waiting for.
And then out all that comes,
you know,
soldiers should Ipsen when he was in the
concentration camps in Russia watching
how people behaved,
you know,
he said that there were people that were
put into camps who immediately became
trustees are guards and they were even
more vicious than the people who had
been hired as guards.
And his idea was that they had collected
all that.
He called it fallenness,
if I remember correctly around them in
normal life.
But they didn't have the opportunity to
express it.
But as soon as you gave them the
opportunity,
it was like there,
it was right away.
And so,
so one of the messages that seems to
echo through these old testament stories
is that just because something terrible
happens to you doesn't mean that you get
to be,
that you get to wander off the path and
make things worse.
And maybe it doesn't matter how terrible
it is that what happens to you,
that's a tough call,
you know,
because you see people now and then in
life who they've really got it rough
man,
like 50 bad things are happening to them
at the same time.
And you think,
oh,
it's no wonder if you are bitter and
resentful and hostile.
It'd be like,
yeah,
no wonder.
But then you meet people and social hits
and again talked about this in the Gulag
archipelago.
He said he met lots of people in a not
lot.
He met enough people to impress him in
the concentration camp system who didn't
allow their misfortunes to corrupt them.
And that's something man,
because maybe the only real misfortune
is to become corrupted.
That's a really useful thing to think,
you know,
maybe the rest of it,
maybe the rest of it is trivial in
comparison.
I know that's a rough thing because you
can be in very harsh circumstances,
but I do think there's something to that
and the Lord was with Joseph and he was
a prosperous man and he was in the house
of his master.
The Egyptian and his master saw that the
Lord was with him and the Lord made all
that he did to prosper in his hand.
So that's an echo of the idea that we
encountered earlier about walking with
God.
Right.
So Adam walked with God before he ate
the fruit with eve and then he wouldn't
walk with God and they had noah walked
with God and Abraham walked with God.
And so the idea is,
well,
that's that alignment with the highest
ideal.
I think it's something like that and you
know,
we can think about that as a
metaphysical claim as well,
but I don't think it is.
I mean,
I've got thousands of letters now in the
last year from people who have told me
that they were in a pit.
That's exactly right,
and that they decided that they were
going to try to put their lives together
and that it worked and so that's really
something,
you know,
when they write surprised,
it's like,
well,
I decided that I was going to work hard
at what I was doing and I wasn't going
to lie any more than absolutely
necessary.
I thought I'd give it a try for a few
months,
you know,
and all sorts of good things started to
happen.
To me it's like maybe that's how the
world works now.
Obviously it doesn't work like that all
the time.
Right.
Because you can get sliced off at the
knees.
I mean there's an arbitrary element to
existence that's that you can't wish
away,
but that doesn't mean that there are.
It doesn't mean that there aren't bad
strategies and good strategies.
So I do think that one of the most
fundamental existential questions is
like,
if things are going well for you in your
life,
is are you absolutely certain that
you're doing absolutely everything you
can to put things in order?
Because if you're not,
then you shouldn't complain because you
don't know to what degree you're
actually contributing or even causing
the circumstance.
Now,
that's a very annoying thing to think,
and I'm not trying to blame the victim.
You know,
I know that people end up with lung
cancer because they were exposed to
asbestos.
You know,
I'm not trying to.
Although I also know too that if you
have lung cancer because you've been
exposed to asbestos,
that can be a tragedy or can be hell.
And to some degree,
that depends on how you conduct
yourself.